what is it about the mafia that people
find so fascinating
it's about the power
about the ability to do anything you
want and no one could touch
you but the more powerful they get
sooner or later someone is going to
betray you
and in the end
it's always a friend who does the deed
you go into the military they say sell
you the dream what's the dream the dream
is
women like men in uniform you're going
to walk in the mall women are going to
come up to you you're going to go party
you're going to have a great time travel
see the world that's how they sold the
dream in the nba when you get into the
nba you're going to have a big house the
big cars the big lifestyle the nice
clothes the nice watch the nice this
the dream you're going to hollywood
you're going to be a star your picture's
going to be everywhere
what's the mafia what's the lacrosse i
don't know
a ceremony who would tell you that well
what is the dream what what's the dream
what's your vision is power you've
worked for it this secret society these
were idols to you when you go back like
i said the lucky luciano's
all of these people
they they're part of your heritage
they're part of your life his father was
an idol not only to him as a son but to
a lot of people
so
becoming
becoming made is becoming
sunny francis sammy i got to tell you
something i love my dad but all he ever
talked to me about was making money that
was it this was awesome if anybody needs
money listen the guy was broke he was in
prison he was doing tough time you
lawyers were chewing them up of course
he's going to talk to you about what i'm
saying
the
lifestyle is built on money and power
just going back
when i took that oath i thought it was
the greatest thing in the world i mean
that night i was on a high i was
exhilarated you know to me it was
everything because we felt
it was an honorable life it was a
brotherhood
patrick nothing stronger than
a a group of guys and a brotherhood
having each other's backs accepting and
shifting and that's why he's high as a
kind he's accepted by pete exactly some
of them are dirty or ugly but most of
them are not yeah michael wherever you
go in the world you'll have somebody to
have your back you don't have to worry
about anything don't ever worry about
your mother your sister your wife your
daughter nobody's ever going to violate
that
i mean when you hear those words it's
powerful
the problem is like anything else
it's not the way it is all the time
right it's just not and look i'll say
this about my dad
my dad and i had a lot of talks
privately a lot of things would were
done
with him that i was upset about
my dad was deep
if you had to put him there's nobody
he does nobody better him as far as a
stand-up guy in that life
nobody you know but there was things
that we said privately and he said mike
this life is [ __ ]
he would tell you that absolutely he
said that ain't the way they're going to
tell you it is
there was times when my dad was a
captain and they broke him and i bet he
broke okay and i i i bet he would tell
you
it's not what it used to be
exactly you know okay so at one point he
loved the life and it changed what same
person
same thing with me i love the life i
still like it well you got to know the
life sam and john
the betrayal i said the same thing as
you thought [ __ ] this life and then and
left because betrayal happens all the
time and i'm happier now or patrick yeah
and to sit down then i am with the life
betrayal happens all the time is that
inevitable it happens all the time is it
inevitable change yes
betrayal yes
it's inevitable yeah you know what
greed
envy jealousy
that's a way of life
not everybody has it
but i don't care who you are you're
going to bunk into it
and my suggestion as a main guy when you
bunk into somebody who has those
qualities
greed
envy and jealousy get the [ __ ] up get
worse than a rapist or get away from
those people don't do business with them
don't do nothing get away because they
will betray
it's stuck in them
and guys that you didn't expect to
betray betrayed you can those guys
change
no they're like they're almost like a
child boys but it's in them it's part of
their life carmine mendoza when i was
again young he told me he told me that
sammy
i i think you're a great kid you're
growing up the right way you've got a
lot of scoopers and balls if this you
live with me people like this get away
from them they're the worst things that
you could